Das ist eine Fragenlotterie mit fiesen und netten Fragen
Du hast die Wahl, die Roten sind die fiesen und die Grünen sind die netten.
-Ich versuche es es zu erst mit einer Grünen
Okay wir beginnen
Es ist sehr... Einfach wegdrehen
-Ist sie in englisch?
Ja, sie ist in englisch!
-Sonst könnte ich sie ja nicht vorlesen
-Wie hast du es geschafft, solch wundervolle Töchter zu erziehen
-Eine tolle Frage!
-Ich habe es es geschafft, weil ich Ihnen immer die Wahrheit gesagt habe.
-Ich sagte “Ihr könnt das machen, was ihr für richtig haltet. “
-Ich kann euch nichts verbieten, aber ich kann euch über die Konsequenzen eures Handelns aufklären
-Was passiert, wenn ihr euch für das Eine entscheidet oder dieses oder jenes tut
-Ich werde euch sagen welche Konsequenzen es nach sich zieht.
-Und ich war immer ehrlich zu ihnen
-Und wenn ich Fehler mache, dann entschuldige ich mich dafür, dass
ich mich unverantwortlich benommen habe.
-Denn ich habe die Verantwortung euer Vater zu sein und zwar immer
-Und Ehrlichkeit, ist das Beste, was du deinen Kindern geben kannst
-Weil sie dann auch dir gegenüber ehrlich sind
-Und der einzige Weg dieses Leben zu meistern ist, jemanden zu haben, der dich liebt und dir
die Wahrheit erzählt
-Wenn nicht, dann ist es schlecht
-Und das ist, was vielen Menschen passiert. Unter anderem Michael Jackson
-Jemand musste ihm die Wahrheit sagen
-Es ist wichtig, dass du deinen Kindern gegenüber ehrlich bist!
Guter Punkt
-Ja
Sehr guter Punkt
So jetzt nimm bitte eine fiese Frage
Na ja nicht wirklich fiese, nur ein wenig
-Oh, das ist toll
-Das ist sehr Spaßig
-Das verursacht bei mir Lampenfieber
-Ist es wahr?
-Du hast einen kleinen Hammer!
-Ne, nein, ich weiß es nicht!
-Kannst du dich selbst noch ernst nehmen, nachdem du in einem Film wie
Spongebob mitgespielt hast?
-Absolut!
-Niemand kann mich in Verlegenheit bringen!
-Noch nicht ein mal ich selbst kann mich in Verlegenheit bringen!
-Spongebob ist großartig! Spongebob rockt!
-Ich habe eine Statue von Davin Hasselhoff, die sieht so aus
-In meinem Haus!
-Sie ist 750 Pfund schwer und 12 Fuß lang
-Und ich liebe Spongebob
-Spongebob rockt!
-Patrick ist ein wenig schwul, aber Spongebob ist wirkich sehr, sehr cool!
-Ich liebe Spongebob, es ist sogar meine Lieblingssendung
Alles klar
-Das ist nicht fies
Okay, noch 2. Nur noch 2 Fragen bitte
-Ich dachte das wird sehr hart
Es ist Spaß!
-Das ist toll!
-Das ist auf eine Art unheimlich
Lampenfieber
-Ja
Du hast eine rote Frage gezogen.
-Bist du nur in den Ländern erfolgreich, in den niemand deine Lieder versteht?
-Ja, ich bin nur so lange erfolgreich, bis jemand anfängt meine Liedtexte zu verstehen
-Und wenn sie die Liedtexte verstehen, dann fragen sie mich “Was ist falsch mit dir?”
-”Warum singst du diese Songtexte?
-Ich bin erfolgreich im Vereinigtem Königreich für die Rolle in “Peter Pan”
-Ich bin erfolgreich in Amerika, wenn ich amerikanische Lieder singe. Ich glaube nicht, dass
ich “Limbo Dance” in Amerika singen kann.
-Das ist eine wirklich witzige Frage!
-Wer hat diese Frage geschrieben?
-Verstehst du nicht meine Lieder “Crazy for you”, nein? Nicht?
-Manchaml verstehe selbst ich die Texte nicht
-Und ehm...
-Weißt du...
-Ich meine... Der Songtext von “A Whiter Shade of Pale”
-Schon mal was davon gehört?
-Ich wähle den “night fandango”
-Ich meine, was soll das bedeuten?
-Wenn du den Schreiber nach der Bedeutung fragst sagt er “Ich weiß es nicht, ich war so  “drauf” … Ich habe einfach fandango geschrieben.
-Was zum Teufel ist fandango?
-Niemand hat wirklich, wen interessieren überhaupt die Songtexte?!
-Niemanden interessieren die Songtexte, die Leute interessieren sich für die Melodie!
Aber die Frauen interessieren sich für die Songtexte
-Oh, ja ich weiß, die lieben Frauen  interessieren sich für die Songtexte, wenn du Balladen singst.
Okay, vielen Dank